en el partido de los republicanos el
voto es 100% en línea en parís los
apoderados del partido se movilizaron
para ayudar a los mayores a seguir cada
paso vote y después ingresé su código
jean-jacques de 81 años acaba de
conseguir su carnet del partido de los
republicanos y puede elegir entre cinco
candidatos pero cuando intentamos tener
más información
espero que el que llegue a la cabeza
en la fila de espera esta mañana sólo
una militante acepta confiarnos su
preferencia y fémur he elegido ya tengo
a mi candidato el mejor eric ciotti
y precisamente en la nisa natal de eric
ciotti los militantes también se
apresuraron a votar como en parís con
una idea en mente
cientos del boston pues kris y polacos
el hongo es muy importante porque es por
francia que votamos y para tener a
alguien competente que asuma el cargo de
presidente la plaza difícil
además de miembros permanentes del
partido están presentes representantes
de cada candidato
sólo vengo a asegurarme de la honestidad
de las operaciones de voto igual que los
representantes de los otros candidatos
controlar que todo vaya bien exactamente
eso es todo de momento no se ha
denunciado ninguna irregularidad en esta
votación interna con tanta seguridad
este jueves por la tarde se sabrá quién
entre xavier bertrand valérie pécresse
michel barnier ix yo tío phillips-van
pasará a la segunda vuelta interna de
este fin de semana